hey everybody welcome back to reality
check now every now and again a
videogame comes along that just makes
you want to show what the hell science
where is this tech in real life you got
it yeah my friend Titan form enter
titanfall EA and respawn Entertainment's
Mac based answer to Call of Duty now for
me this is definitely one such game but
don't get me wrong I'm in no hurry to
see terrifying new ways of gunning down
blowing up and punching people into mist
but mechs like these Titans are a staple
of science fiction battlefield and the
idea of having a giant walking suit of
armor to zip around fightin and above
all else to protect the squishy pilots
inside is actually pretty exciting sell
then exactly how close are we to
building Titans in real life
[Music]
it probably won't surprise you that
there are no Titans or mechs in
deployment in war zones around the world
today but what about in military
research and development do we have a
Titan sitting deep underground in a
research facility someplace or at least
on a drawing board well this is probably
the closest thing we're gonna get for
the moment not Titan but Talos or
tactical assault light operator suit
developed by the US Army it's an
advanced infantry uniform that promises
to provide superhuman strength with
greater ballistic protection the idea
apparently came about from a knee
protect but for a first guy through the
door in a combat situation now obviously
this is just a promo animation for now
but the US military have a huge number
of partners involved in this project and
are apparently aiming to have three
separate unpowered prototypes of Talos
available for testing as early as this
summer now I say unpowered because the
ultimate goal of this towel system is to
combine these prototype armored suits
with powered exoskeleton technology tech
like the Raytheon XO s - weighing in at
95 kilograms this wearable high-strength
aluminium and steel robotic suit
increases the strength agility and
endurance capabilities of the soldier
inside it the Robo muscle comes from
high-pressure hydraulics giving the
wearer a 17 fold increase in power so
say you can comfortably curl a 10
kilogram dumbbell on your own well this
suits in theory should let you curl 170
kilograms while exerting the very same
level of force as before now while a
left hook from someone wearing this
would definitely be no laughing matter
these guys are not actually being
developed for combat use the former
practical application is for the lifting
and carrying of supplies in a
battlefield environment the one major
downside at the moment however is that
this thing needs a whopping great load
of electrical power so much in fact it
needs to be constantly tethered to a
generator the folks at Raytheon are
working on a backpack power solution
however so hopefully this hurdle can be
jumped soon
or just smashed out of the way whichever
and you know what this could be sooner
rather than later the army are aiming to
field-test power talo systems as early
as 2018 okay so the whole talo system is
undeniably impressive but it's not a
Titan so why are there no giant walking
battle tanks actually in development
what's the reason well now obviously I'm
no engineer but the main issue with this
design I think is that large bipedal
objects while awesome-looking
just aren't the best design for a
gunfight
being tall makes you an easy target plus
a real Titan would likely be unstable
due to their colossal weight and
ultimately just not as maneuverable as
things on wheels also military research
and development just isn't really going
this way rather than encasing the
soldier inside a protective Robo suit
the focus is more on removing the human
being from the combat situation
altogether where possible and replacing
them with autonomous robots to see the
real cutting edge of this technology
just check out any of the machines under
development by Boston Dynamics they're
equal parts impressive and terrifying
for more on this why not take a trip
down memory lane and check out the Robot
Wars episode of the what-if machine
speaking of terrifying what is with this
guy's hair okay now before you leave
this video too disappointed I've got one
more thing to show you now you see it
actually possible to get your hands on
climb inside and drive around in a
real-life mech today in the year 2014
all you need is 1.3 million dollars say
hello to Curtis created by Co Gordo
Kurata this beast is four metres tall
and can achieve speeds of up to six
miles per hour
plus it's r2 the BB minigun and water
bottles watch out world Kurata said he
built the thing to bring to life the
machines from his childhood fantasies da
okay so that's nearly it for this week's
episode
are you disappointed by the lack of
Titan like battle bots in real life do
you let me know in the comments
below oh and also from now on in reality
check I'm gonna end every episode by
addressing questions or comments from
you guys in last week's episode on video
game guns in real life I included some
footage showing deers being hunted and
shot with one of the guns featured in
the episode now that footage was from
the actual promotional video produced by
the company who make the weapon which is
why I included it in the show now a
number of you guys commenting that you
found this footage upsetting or
offensive so I just wanted to make an
unreserved apology for that I really
should have thought twice about
including it really and I will with
things like this in the future but thank
you for letting me know
and I do understand that it's not really
something you expect to see in a show
about video games ok well thanks for
watching as ever and I'll be back same
time next week for more reality check
[Music]